[Applause]
how are you all doing today Aaron
Sampson here with Ryan Schubert and
we're back talking about more tactical
shooters our last video was about
insurgency sandstorm which you guys
liked and today we're gonna take a look
at firewall zero-hour and why you're why
you keyboard warriors out there are
missing out on some stuff that you can't
actually do unless you're playing a game
like this firewall is your hour for
those who don't know it's for it's a
psvr title that's coming out August 28th
you do need the psvr and we play with a
name controller although you can play
with your DualShock and with the
DualShock the weapon is still Unchained
from your head which is awesome it's
actually one of the cool things right of
playing a VR shooter is having that sort
of sense of space and the separation
between head and gun that's like one of
the biggest things that you don't get
from mouse and keyboard when you walk
around these maps you'll see that I have
the weapon pinned to my shoulder and
when you watch tactical videos and
movies you're always asking yourself
like if you're a PC gamer you're always
asking yourself why are they walking
around with their weapon up like that
all the time you can see so much more
with our weapon down you take for
granted in console and PC games that
your aim just snaps to the middle of the
screen but when you've got our red dot
sight in front of you like a real
simulated red dot sight it don't work
that way and if you don't keep track of
it if you don't keep it in the middle of
your eyes it goes all over the place you
just lose sight of it and it's hard to
get it back up and in a fight oh yeah
I've played a whole bunch of payday 2 VR
not too long ago yeah weird you think
about that I thought it was great
actually I you know I tried onward at
one point and I had trouble with the
motion I had trouble with you know
basically aiming or you know telling the
difference between enemies and friends
and blah blah blah but payday 2 was
like it was a VR payday the port is
excellent
it's my poor dead teammate and one of
the things that's kind of cool about it
is that the game you know you have to
learn how to play the game a little bit
differently in payday 2 just normally I
might have certain loadouts that I
prefer I'm kind of like generally
speaking in first-person shooters kind
of more of a DMR guy but I learned very
quickly that you know getting a getting
a ACOG scope to cooperate in a very
panic situation is not that ideal and
while that could definitely be seen as a
fault for VR the other thing that's kind
of cool is that it brings other play
styles out that can be more exciting
like you know you're playing a bank
heist game and it's kind of cool to be
able to run with two handguns like
you're in a John Woo movie or Reservoir
Dogs or something and that is a totally
different experience because not having
your hands tethered to your face the way
it is in a when you're playing mouse and
keyboard is very very liberating and
also it's way easier to miss yeah that's
the other thing like you can you can go
duel duel hand guns but you're more
likely to just miss twice as much if you
don't aim that's really it's really fun
some things are way tricky so the coop
that I'm showing you here was actually
hired the highest level you go in the
game at this point it was level 50 and
we lost all day this is actually the
final round where me and another guy
held it down at the end of the day but
this was the first one that we actually
want it was very difficult to like so
it's interesting I that kind of brings
up another point which is that you know
VR games are still games so there's two
different things you're dealing with one
is the just coolness of holding these
weapons in real life or like in a more
real life situation and like handling
them but then there's also the gaming
aspects and in the gaming aspects
firewall zero-hour on many maps had a
lot of angles to cover almost too many
angles to cover for the speed that you
could actually turn around paydays a
little bit like that too actually so it
was interesting there
times where we've just be in open spaces
and I just felt like I couldn't possibly
cover every angle now some of that some
of that is the areas that you're forced
to defend because a lot of these are
defending or attacking I'm hacking a
laptop and some of it is up to you it's
it's picking the right gadgets taking an
ammo bag taking mines and taking the
right route through a map which makes it
more exciting a teach you got this B you
got this 85 86 92 coming
oh my god it's interesting this this is
labeled as a tactical game I think you
and I were talking the other day about
what's the line in video games in
general for what's tactical I think the
word tactical gets thrown around quite a
lot and it's I think more loosely used
as an aesthetic but when I think about
what is like legitimately tactical
gameplay I think of games that involve
teamwork use of gadgets lots of problem
solving and communication to me is what
separates something that is tactical
from something that is more or less just
a run-and-gun experience so yeah like
it's tactically skinned this game does
have a lot of the gamey elements though
so there's like a revived pistol there's
a device to prevent the other team from
hacking the laptop or helping your team
hack the laptop faster just a lot of
cool little gaming touches that I enjoy
quite a lot so there are some like
support elements to the character types
or is it class-based it's loadout based
okay and to be fair we everything was
unlocked for us we were at level 50 so I
can't actually speak to what that unlock
tree is going to be like for players on
day one one of the things that actually
doesn't have you brought up earlier you
said you're a DMR player it doesn't have
a scoops of magnification and the
developers gave me an interesting
explanation basically that you have to
render the screen twice it's a render
yeah so it basically kills the
performance of the game and they
couldn't get it in they said they would
like to get it in the future but you are
stuck with sort of red dot sights and
just trying to tell what something is
across a level by looking at it and if
anything actually trying to manage a red
dot sight in a VR game is very difficult
already I can't even imagine trying to
deal with what simulating a lens in
actual lenses like and again like it's I
mean in pay day and onward it's it's
definitely kind of jarring it's cool
but it's jarring and kind of difficult
to use like if I've hit myself in the
face many times trying to aim down sight
alright so that was firewalled zero-hour
that's out August 28th at $39.99 you do
need a psvr to play it it's 4 V for PvP
I would say it's like a siege light game
attack and defend laptops and then it
also has one to four player co-op which
I would say is maybe you know one
objective payday frantic and crazy I had
a really good time playing it a report
just came out this week that there were
three million psvr units sold which is
about 4% of PlayStation owners so I
suppose if you are part of that 4% and
you're looking for a pretty fun tactical
shooter to play this is a one you should
check out looks pretty cool to me one
last thing games comps coming up next
week and we've got a crew out in Germany
checking out all the latest tiles for
you guys including World War three which
we're gonna get a reveal of yeah I'm
kind of curious to see what World War
three is like all right have a good day
everyone
[Laughter]
I can't see them anymore